apaiser les tensions interculturelles
utiliser l'art pour améliorer notre
vivre ensemble c'est l'invitation lancée
par la fondation fille ça nous donne
l'opportunité à discuter de ces
questions de parler de la racj la
racialisation de parler de la question
d'appartenance mais aussi c'est quoi la
joie d'être multi valence dans sa façon
de voir le monde en vedette
24 artistes d'origines diverses qui
partagent un point commun le talent il
faut qu'on arrête de se dire que vous
n'y a pas beaucoup d'artistes de couleur
ou d'origine autochtone qui exerce le
métier de entre guillemets qualité ces
fausses des réflexions intimes mais
capable de toucher tout le monde dit
cette réflexion en fait sur mon
déplacement sur mes origines sur le lieu
où j'habite l'histoire du lieu où
j'habite
qu'est-ce que ça produit comme effet sur
moi
ses oeuvres inspirées des lignes de la
main sont une réflexion sur l'identité
pour moi en tout cas l'identité c'est
plusieurs couches parce qu'avec le temps
il ya des choses qui changent et des
choses qui évoluent à des choses qu'on
prend d'autres personnes dont on
s'inspire et ça nous construisons nous
forme manuel mathieu est un artiste
incontournable cette saison en plus de
l'exposition affi ces oeuvres seront
présentées au musée des beaux arts de
montréal au mac et à la galerie par le
point de toronto
j'essaie de changer les choses puis je
regarde pas ce qui fonctionne pas pour
dire ben là comme ça fonctionne pas un
problème quand j'arrivais ici moi je me
suis même pas posé la question mais pas
du tout ok je vais essayer d'aller
frapper notre la galerie à l'appel de
regroupement never was average stimuler
pour une culture inclusive
les artistes issus de la diversité
culturelle s'expose aussi sur la rue
sainte catherine
on a des personnes de différentes
nationalités différentes communautés qui
viennent des personnes planchent
également qui viennent donc c'est
vraiment un espace ouvert à tous et
c'est je pense un espace où ce que tout
le monde se rejoint sur une base humaine
une visibilité grandissante mais une
juste place au soleil qui reste à
conquérir
ben c'est ça a été de créer des
événements des festivals des expos au
fait c'est sûr que c'est une des pistes
de de s'assurer nous même d'avoir la
place qu'on veut avoir à attendre qu'on
nous la donne
ces artistes d'origines diverses aux
regard aiguisé sur notre monde métissé
et entend bien exposer leurs couleurs
kiss in a dit alexandre chartier
radio-canada à montréal